civilization
is a mirror of our consciousness
an enlightened civilization is aware
of our shared eternity
an enlightened civilization is aware
of ourselves as the one infinite creator
expressing itself
as these dreamed creation designs this
is just
one combination this is just one
expression how many
possibilities are there of songs that a
symphony can play
this is one of those songs that we are
playing as the eternal symphony
an enlightened civilization has that
recognition
and it becomes a clean mirror that
refracts the source light
purely without any distortions
when the mirror the jewel that is being
refracted
through is dirty that's where
distortions happen
that's when the unique expressions the
artists
in the symphony play out of tune that's
when
planetary ecological disaster happens
that's when self-dealing and ego and
greed
and conspicuous consumption and seeking
happiness and peace
externally happen
it all has to do with how cleanly that
mirror
is how pure that mirror is versus how
dirty it is and how distorted it is
and you can analyze that through our
technology at a civilizational level
what level of enlightenment is our
technology
you have all of the double-edgedness in
all of the tech that we make you make an
incredible democratization in some
technology like these incredible
computers and
smartphones and they're being used both
in great ways to maximize our potential
and also in very destructive ways
simultaneously so at a level of
consciousness the more enlightened we
become the more that the technology
becomes architected to maximize
prosperity
very similar with our governments you
look at our governments today
it's very much like these institutions
they look like
they are hundreds of years old
they look like they're there to serve
as a kleptocracy for just the select few
elites
rather than to serve the maximization of
the
potential of everybody that's a part of
that country in that government
also our social contracts very similarly
when you have a relationship
with your physician as a patient
why is your physician getting the
incentives from the pharmaceutical
industry like the sackler family in
purdue pharma to prescribe you
opiates rather than
having the incredible benefits of so
many of the entheogens that are
currently
illegal the natural secretions of the
planet are illegal
meanwhile what's synthetically being
made inside of a lab
to make you a
dodo bird that becomes extinct to make
you gluttonous
to make you have
heart disease and high blood pressure
and high blood sugar
and cancer is legal but
while the planetary secretions of
entheogens that unleash god within
are illegal how enlightened
is our civilization when we see these
types
of social contract architectures the
physician
should have a tokenomic inclusive equity
stake
in the life outcome of their patient
that would eradicate
any of the perverse incentives of the
pharmaceutical industry getting involved
or at an ecological level look at the
planetary social fabric
how well do we recognize our depth of
interconnectedness
20 000 times per day we take an
inhalation of oxygen that comes directly
from the photosynthesis of phytoplankton
and trees
and yet you wonder how aware we are of
that as we continue
creating the
clear
lack of harmony with our
environment
ecologically speaking this is our
home we are secreted and maintained by
the planet
and so to be stupid enough
to not recognize that
is a level of consciousness that is so
dim
this so unenlightened so in darkened
that of course we're gonna have all of
these mirrored
problems that are happening at our
civilizational level look at it at a
geopolitical level
in the sense of the left versus right
politically in the united states or even
at the level of geopolitically with
china and the us
or russia saudi arabia etc
it just looks like a bunch of monkeys
that are throwing
feces at each other's faces none of it
looks like
a conversation around how to maximize
planetary enlightenment how to maximize
human potential across the board for
everybody
it's a it's a big competition to
self-deal as much as you can for
yourselves and your own countries
meanwhile everybody else they're not
important to me and even then when you
get into your own country
then you say well it's actually about my
family and it's not about any of the
other families
you see the level of endarkenment
is exactly the level of
civilizational architectures social
contracts governments
institutions technology ecological
relations geopolitical relations
the more in darkened you are the more
dirty the mirror is the more cancerous
and pathological
everything downstream is versus the more
enlightened we are
the more clear our channel is the more
clean
and pure our mirror is and the more
harmonic
and the more prosperous our downstream
architectures are
it's that simple it has everything to do
with
consciousness you can literally think
about it at a level of frequency and
vibration
you have this low level of frequency and
vibration around and darkened souls
those are very egoic there's a lot of
noise it's like the mass
media it's like gluttony it's like
polarization very dirty mirror
and then there's this very subtle higher
frequency vibration that exists
which is the signal in the noise and you
have to parse and you have to find that
signal and
fill your essence your spirit your
neural real estate with that on a
moment-to-moment basis to become more
enlightened
and to then vortex up other people with
you
and that's what god slash infinity
realization and actualization
is that's what a clean mirror is you
purify and you purify yourself
away from these animalistic behaviors
and
tendencies that are egoic and finite
and contracted and you clean and purify
that mirror
more and more towards one infinite
creator to recognize that the pupil
is shared and eternal among us and that
the iris is our unique expression of the
infinite our
unique coloration and that this is just
one creation design that is dreamed that
we are experiencing
as eternal awareness
and so you have to do your best to find
those pockets of signal
in the insanity of the noise and to
really hone in
on that signal and then vortex up more
and more people towards that enlightened
signal
there's been a lot of conversations in
the media around
aliens and it's been really exciting
because i've been studying this for
five plus years and it's like finally
people are catching up
in a respect especially around these
topics first of all is the zoo
hypothesis
you have to think about all of this at a
very macro level
the zoo hypothesis is simply put
something like
the other civilizations that exist that
are advanced in the cosmos
they will not touch this civilization
here on this rock on this earth orbiting
the star
because it is very much like the
naturalistic evolutionary capacities and
tendencies like a big social experiment
like a petri dish that is unfolding and
that's also very similar to the prime
directive which comes from star trek
which says that these massive star
fleets of starships
that are going around in the cosmos of
these advanced civilizations
their prime directive is to not
influence
the evolution of the civilization now
there might be tiny bits of evolution
that is affected by the advanced
civilizations
in the sense of when you look back at
things like
around 1945 when the nuclear weapons
are created and dropped on hiroshima
nagasaki
simultaneously albert hoffman
synthesizes
lsd and that gets unleashed into the
civilization
right so you might wonder that if there
are those tiny
vibrational influences that come and
assist
in the ascension and the enlightenment
and similarly in 2008
when you have the subprime mortgage
crisis hit and the recession hit
you have literally six weeks after
lehman brothers collapses you have
satoshi nakamoto publish
the bitcoin white paper which we still
don't know who that is
if it is potentially something that is
off world that comes and affects this
which is very beautiful
also thinking about aliens and this
conversation of consciousness around the
kardashev scale
the more that a civilization advances on
the kardashev scale
from being a type one civilization where
we as a planet are still at a point
seven
a type one civilization is one that
knows how to ecologically harmonically
leverage the resources energetically
of its own rock we still don't know how
to do that because we're creating
destructive ecology
while we extract for energetic purposes
a type 2 civilization on a kardashev
scale knows how to extract
the resources from their host star
and a type 3 civilization knows how to
extract the resources from all of the
stars
in their galaxy type 4 civilization
knows how to extract
the energy from at the universal level
and a type 5 civilization the omega
civilization knows how to do things like
create more universes which is
ultimately what is at our god head
in the transcension hypothesis as well
we both go
inward into the metaverse technology the
synthesis
of artificial general intelligence
indistinguishable virtual realities bio
and neurotechnology
as well as we go outward at the same
time into the cosmos
in that star trek and style future
simultaneously we go
both in and out that is ultimately what
is at our god head
is the cyclic cosmology like sir roger
penrose won the nobel prize in physics
in 2020
talking about the cyclic cosmology or
looking at it from the perspective
of what the perennial wisdoms are across
the spiritual traditions it's the
oroboros
which is the snake eating its own tail
so more
and more of these dream creation designs
that we eternally
will be experiencing we are infinity
experiencing
these dreams creation designs
that shared pupil and then the unique
coloration of the iris
and as we birth out of egoic adolescence
to be able to play with others in this
cosmic landscape
think about that when a civilization
becomes enlightened
when all eight billion of us figure out
how to
harmonically maximize human potential to
recognize that the other
is actually the self it's actually a
unique expression of the same
infinity then you recognize let's
maximize human potential
everybody's a unique creative expression
but of the same infinite
so what we'll do is then become so
advanced we'll break out of our egoic
contracted finite
separate energy and then we will attract
more of the cosmic levels of
intelligence to play with
us very simple
and this also goes with these beautiful
quotes that many of us have heard show
me your friends
i'll show you your future very similar
to show me the incentives
i'll show you the future which is very
similar to show me your consciousness
i'll show you your future
and show me civilizations consciousness
i'll show you civilization's future
it all has to do with the levels of
consciousness
consciousness is the fundamental unit
that is then reflected in our social
fabric
the more egoic of a level of
consciousness you have
the more you'll have disastrous
relationships with your family your
friends your community in the world
the more enlightened your level of
consciousness is the more you recognize
that the shared infinitude and eternity
of
our nature and therefore the more
harmonic
your relationships are with your friends
your families
your co-workers your community in the
world it's
that simple stop surrounding yourself
with the gowick friends cut it off
go and begin surrounding yourself with
more enlightened friends
similarly with incentives get away from
perverse incentives and move towards
the architecting of incentives that are
around inclusive stakeholding inclusive
equity
and same thing with our consciousness
hone in dedicate yourself
fully to enlightenment dedicate yourself
fully to purify and cleansing your
mirror to become a better and better
refracting
agent of that source light so that more
and more
your expression is less and less egoic
and more and more
of the recognition of that god realized
state of
the shared eternal one infinite creator
expressing itself
and that's why one of the first things
that i do
all the time now is i ask about
metaphysical truth
not only a couple years ago as i began
going full time into recognizing what is
our metaphysics what is consciousness
what is
the nature of reality who are we why are
we here where are we going
but beyond that is even asking
every single person you interact with
about
their understanding of metaphysics
gauging the person's
level of consciousness right off the bat
that way you know where they're at are
they at an egoic level of consciousness
are they at a somewhat enlightened level
of consciousness
are they literally radiating peace and
bliss
where are they at and that way you gain
deep
insight immediately
into the relationship with them
rather than staying at the surface level
talking about the weather and talking
about
sports and talking about the news go
deep right away
do you know yourself as infinity
right away ask
don't be scared don't let fear
create hesitation practice the process
over and over again if asking people
that
do you recognize yourself as infinity
are you an expression of the infinite
do you recognize our awareness as shared
do you recognize that awareness as
eternal
do you recognize this as a dreamed
creation design
how focused are you on planetary
prosperity
those are the questions
eradicate the limiting beliefs that hold
you
back from god realization from infinite
realization
and then eradicate the limiting beliefs
on the channeling of that realization
outward like wu way like lao said in an
effortless butterfly effect
outward recognize the optimizations that
exist in the infinite
actualization in the god actualization
process
where you can become better and better
and more optimal and more optimal
at for example disseminating your
mimetics becoming a better storyteller
having a higher digital quotient knowing
how to leverage
the social platforms
and have the courage to actualize your
fullest firework
the firework is very dim the dirty ass
mirror versus the firework that's
massive and explosive and brings so much
peace and bliss to everybody
have the courage to be that
that is your true nature is the pure and
clean
mirror expression of infinity that is
your true nature
it is a very simple veilless
veil or gateless gate that must be
pierced
to recognize that as your true nature as
infinity you are already in union
with infinity but the noisy mind
prevents this insight and that's why
patanjali
2000 years ago said
yogas
with the infinite is simply quieting
the waves the fluctuations of
consciousness
when you quiet the mind it gives you
profound
insight into union with infinity and
then you bring that out and weave
tantric path the realization sahaja
samadhi as ramana maharshi said
out into society you weave those
realizations
you maximize human potential by
architecting out the protocols the
frameworks
that bring abundance and prosperity and
well-being to everybody because you
recognize our shared eternal
being you recognize that
we are the infinite expressing itself
the more that you recognize that the
more enlightened you become
and the more enlightened civilization
becomes civilization
all our technology our governments our
ecological relationships geopolitical
relationships our social contracts
are all a mirror of
our states of consciousness are we
egoic or are we enlightened
it's as simple as that parse
for the signal in
all of the noise of the gluttony
all of the mass media propaganda and
polarization and nonsense that's
salt oil sugar trying to keep you
sedated
try and parse for the
signal of enlightenment of piercing that
veil of surveil of god realizing
infinite realizing and then infinity
actualizing the bright ass
firework that you are clean pure
mirror refracting the source light
rather than the dirty jewel that is
refracting egoic
tendencies it's really that simple
civilization is a mirror of our
consciousness
recognize that and enlighten yourself
seek becoming the one infinite creator
recognizing yourself as that as rumi
said
we go from room to room looking for the
diamond necklace
that is already around our neck that is
what awareness is
become aware of awareness itself
and the eternal sharedness
of that awareness and that is your
ticket that is your key
to recognize that the pupil itself
is that and the iris is the unique
expression
of that we share the eternal
pupil of infinity and the unique
expression
is our iris and when you get that
you elevate your consciousness to those
levels and you elevate
civilizational architectures and
prosperity to those levels
thank you very much for tuning in if the
video brought you value like the video
if you haven't subscribed yet hit the
subscribe button
also leave a comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you
share the video with other people that
you
feel that this would resonate with also
you can join the channel below get cool
exclusive perks
and also every single one of those
revenue dollars goes to the
actualization of all of our projects
and love utahns thank you so much for
tuning in adore you
and
clean the mirror purify the mirror
recognize yourself as the one infinite
creator and civilization architectures
will ascend
with your enlightenment adore you thank
you
you